FRANK: Good afternoon.
Thank you for joining us.
I'm really excited to
introduce Dr. James Shapiro.
Dr. Shapiro's been working
on diabetes research
for a long time, and
in particular he's
credited with
developing the Edmonton
Protocol for human islet
cell transplantation, which
was published in the New
England Journal of Medicine
in the year 2000.
He's currently
continuing this research
at the University of
Alberta in Edmonton, Canada.
And he also holds the
Canadian Research Chair
in transplantation and
regenerative medicine.
Dr. Shapiro's received
quite a lot of awards,
including a Hunterian
medal from the Royal
College of Surgeons of England.
And he's also
recently been inducted
as a fellow of the
Royal Society of Canada.
And with that, please help
me welcome Dr. Shapiro.
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: Frank,
thank you very much indeed.
It's very kind of you
to invite me to Google.
I'm very impressed
with my tour so far.
And I'm very excited
about the discussion
that we're going to have
later on this afternoon.
So it's a great privilege
to be here and be with you
and share our hopes and trials
and tribulations and progress
in some of the treatments for
the condition of diabetes.
So we're trying
to get to a point
where we have
diabetes cured once
and for all for the future.
But it's not easy to do
that in one fell swoop.
So we've got several
strategies, and it's really
a team and global effort
in diabetes research,
to try and take a point
where we have insulin today
and hopefully no injections,
no monitoring for the future.
And I'll try and take
you along that journey
of cutting edge islet and stem
cell transplant treatments
in the clinic for diabetes
as we move forward today.
So diabetes.
Most of you will know
what diabetes is,
but just the start
of the basics.
Diabetes is a condition
where patients
lose the ability to
adjust their blood sugar.
And there are two main
types of diabetes--
there are several subtypes--
but two main types.
Type one, where the
pancreas basically
has lost its ability
to make insulin.
The cells in the pancreas
that make insulin
are called islets of Langerhans.
And inside those collections
of cells there are beta cells,
and those are the beta cells
are the ones that make insulin.
So in someone who has
type I diabetes then
the body has basically destroyed
those cells-- destroyed
the beta cells inside the
pancreas inside the islets
that make insulin.
So the patients have an
absolute deficiency of insulin.
And the other type
of diabetes-- which
is of course much more common
and increasing in number as
well-- is type 2
diabetes, where patients
become resistant to insulin.
And therefore when
they receive insulin,
or the pancreas
is making insulin,
the body's needs for
insulin are basically
what the pancreas can
release is insufficient.
So diabetes is a very
common condition.
There are about
381 million people
with diabetes in
the world today,
based on the world estimates
from the Diabetes Federation
2013.
Type I diabetes represents about
10% of the world population.
By 2030, this population with
type I and type 2 diabetes
will double.
So it's going to be a huge, huge
health burden for the future.
The national cost of diabetes
in this country and the US
alone is greater than $245
billion estimated last year.
And that increased from
$174 billion in 2007.
And clearly, with
the massive increase
in numbers of patients
with diabetes,
this is going to become
uncontrollable and super
saturate the ability
of health care systems
to deliver appropriate care.
So insulin has been around for
a long time, as some of you
may know.
Banting/Best-- and this
is Frederick Banting
in the physiology laboratories
in London, Canada in 1920,
1921, 1922 when the
team was working
on the discovery of insulin
Banting, Best, Collip,
and Macleod.
And insulin injection
therapy clearly
has been life-saving for many,
many patients with type 1
and some patients
with type 2 diabetes.
So injections of
insulin from the outside
can substitute for the pancreas'
ability to make insulin.
And we measure insulin
in the number of units.
So most patients will take 20,
30, 40 units on insulin a day.
And they measure the number
of units of insulin--
it was a crude amount-- it was
the amount of insulin needed,
one unit of instant to cause
hypoglycemia in a rabbit.
That's how they
originally discovered it
when Banting and Best
were working on this.
Diabetes is a dangerous
condition to have overall.
Kidney failure is a
problem-- 25 times more
risk than the
general population.
Heart attacks-- two to
five times more risk
than the general population.
Strokes-- two to
three times more risk.
And life expectancy for
patients with diabetes
is at least 10 years shorter
than the rest of the world
without diabetes.
Diabetes is the leading
cause of vision loss
in working age adults.
It's the commonest cause of
end stage kidney failure,
and of non-traumatic
lower limb amputations,
because the blood
vessels basically
become destroyed when the
body's glucose becomes awry.
There's been lots
of improvements
in the treatment of diabetes
over the course of time.
As I mentioned, before
the discovery of insulin
in 1921, 1922, diabetes
was a fatal condition.
When insulin was first
tried in patients,
it led to complications--
infection, sepsis.
Then there's been
various improvements
in different types of insulin--
short acting, long acting
insulin-- in different
ways of delivering insulin
over the course of time,
including insulin pumps,
including continuous blood
glucose monitoring systems.
And the whole idea here is to
try to tighten up the sugar
control so that patients
are at less risk of getting
the end stage complications
of diabetes-- the micro
and the macro
complications of diabetes.
And the reverse side
of that equation
is we try to tighten
up the control
as the patients get much
more of this condition, which
is a iatrogenic condition--
in other words, caused
by doctors-- which is
called hypoglycemia.
So when the blood sugar falls
below a certain threshold,
then patients
become susceptible,
because the brain absolutely
requires glucose to function.
As soon as the blood glucose
drops below a certain level,
then the brain can
no longer function.
So islet cell transplantation
has been around since the 1970s
experimentally.
And first trials in patients
happened in the 1980s.
And it really took
off in 2000, and there
have been several done.
I'm now going to
explain and tell you
the story about
transportation shortly.
But really our indications
for islet transplantation
have been to try to reduce
this risk of hypoglycemia,
reducing the risk
of lows in patients
that are needing insulin.
So why do we try to run
the blood sugar low?
This is really based on
some very large trials
in patients with diabetes.
We know from these
curves for example,
as we try to tighten up
the blood sugar control,
we can definitely reduce
the risk of complications
such as this one on the right,
called retinopathy, which
is where the blood vessels in
the back of the eye accelerate,
and grow, and cause
the blindness.
But, as we tighten
up the control,
then patients are more and
more at risk of getting lows.
And we measure this by
the glycated hemoglobin,
which is a marker in the
bloodstream that really tells
you how good or
bad the blood sugar
control is over several months.
So here's a patient that's
wearing a state-of-the-art
continuous glucose monitor.
And you can see across
day one and day two,
this patient has quite
wide fluctuations
in blood sugar control.
And at 8:00 in the
morning on the second day,
you can see the
blood glucose drops,
the patient is on their
own, not monitored.
And unfortunately,
that patient's
found dead in bed
at 9:00 an hour
later, from a fatal
hypoglycemic event.
And fortunately, this
is relatively rare,
but it does happen.
And it happens in young
adults with type 1 diabetes
that have poor control.
Now this is what we can achieve
today with an islet cell
transplant in the
lower panel here.
You can see very
wide fluctuations
in blood sugar over
the course of time,
up until that red arrow
when the patient receives
an islet transplant.
This is a transplant that
actually is done in Miami.
Dr. Camillo Ricordi shared
this slide and data with me.
But it's very typical of
what we can achieve routinely
with an islet cell transplant.
And here you can see, after
the islet transplant, when
the patient discontinues
insulin, the blood sugar
control becomes very tight,
is in the normal range
or near normal range.
The price of this however,
is that the patient
needs a procedure-- a small
procedure to receive cells--
and has to have
immunosuppressive drugs
in order for the body not
to reject these cells.
They're transplanted
cells from organ donors,
and they are
therefore potentially
foreign to the body.
And also the process
that caused diabetes
in the first place, which
is an autoimmune process,
meaning the body attacks itself.
This will happen
again after an islet
transparent to the new cells,
unless the anti-rejection drugs
are given.
So there's been real progress
in islet cell transplantation.
I'll explain that to you.
But I think we're somewhere
along this hype cycle
right now, perhaps
somewhere along
the slope of enlightenment.
We haven't got to
Nirvana yet, but we're
trying to get there along
the plateau of productivity.
And still I think
if you can read
and you can Google lots
of negative reviews
on islet transplantation,
because I
think the knowledge
in this area probably
hasn't reached all
of the community.
But I'm sharing with you
today some of the progress.
But there's been progress
throughout diabetes.
And here for example,
is a trial that
was just completed in
September last year, looking
at a special instant pump that
switches off when the blood
sugar reaches a certain low
threshold, low glucose suspend.
And when this is
applied to patients,
then the risk of patients
getting hypoglycemia
is certainly a lot less
than it would be otherwise.
So there's been
lots of progress.
And I'm also very
excited this afternoon
to meet with your Google
contact lens team.
Because I think the areas of
monitoring for blood sugar
control, and our
ability to monitor
the function of our cell
transplant therapies
over time with this
kind of technology
will be enormously informative
and allow us to tighten up
our control, minimize
the stress on the cells,
and allow us all to learn a
lot about controlling diabetes.
So who do we offer an
islet transplant to today?
We have two real
major categories--
those with patients who have
an islet transplant alone.
In other words, they haven't
had a previous transplant.
They have to have
type 1 diabetes
for more than five years.
They have to fail on all the
standard therapies, including
insulin pumps if available.
And we have various
scoring systems,
which I won't dwell on,
but they're basically
to demonstrate that the
patient has severe lows,
despite their ability to control
the glucose as best they can.
And about 5% to 10% of
the population with type 1
diabetes-- at least
in Canada-- would
fulfill these very
strict criteria
to justify adding
immunosuppression and receiving
a cell infusion.
The other side of
the equation are
patients who have already
had a successful transplant,
like a heart, a lung, or in
this case, a kidney transplant.
So they're already on
the anti-rejection drugs,
so they don't have to
face any additional risk
except from the minor risk
of the procedure required
to put the cells in.
And islet after kidney
transplant, or second category,
is becoming a very
successful category too.
So we began with the Edmonton
protocol in the year 2000.
It didn't just
begin from nowhere.
It began from 30
years of research
in small and large
animal models.
And a terrific collaboration
with several international
centers across the world.
And I think that's one of the
privileges involved in science
and in diabetes
research, is that we
have a very, very close knit
community of scientists working
together, willing to share
information and ideas
to allow us all to
get to the next step.
And it probably is
modeled very nicely
in the Google organization.
So we published this in 2000.
This is the New England
Journal of Medicine,
where our first seven
patients receiving islets
under the Edmonton protocol--
that we called subsequently
the Edmonton protocol--
where all the patients that
had the transplants were able to
come off insulin and remain off
insulin for a period of a years.
And in fact, now 15 years
later, two of the original 12
are still completely
insulin-free
with full function.
And we've just
refined this treatment
over the course of time to
try and further improve it.
So this was what we call
the Edmonton protocol.
We gave two sets
of islet infusions.
Initially around 5,000
islets per kilogram
based on the recipient's weight.
And then we have
another infusion
to provide enough
cell mass to make
it sufficient insulin
for the patient.
Then we gave these two
anti-rejection drugs--
sirolimus and tacrolimus-- and
an antibody at the beginning.
And we subsequently
changed these drugs now
to more standard drugs,
because we encountered
quite a lot of side effects
from the sirolimus drug.
But it was certainly
very successful
in allowing us to
begin our first trials.
We then replicated these
trials in Miami, Minnesota,
and in our own site in
Edmonton in 118 patients,
and were able to replicate
this quite successfully in 82%
percent of patients
coming off insulin.
And then we moved forward with
the immune tolerance network
and carried out a large
international trial
in the US and Europe, testing
the Edmonton protocol.
And we published that too
in the New England Journal.
So where are we today?
So we've treated in
Edmonton over 200 patients--
218 patients-- who've
received 460 transplants.
So you can see that
most patients require--
in our center at least--
two islet infusions
to provide sufficient
mass for them
to come off insulin
for a period of time.
We've received in
Canada patients
from all across the country.
Last year we did a record
number of islet transplants
in Edmonton.
We did 66 islet
transplants at Edmonton.
And we're quite proud of that.
We've kept our teams very busy.
Across the world,
currently there've
been over 1,000 islet
transplants done at least
30 different
international sites.
And so I'm going
to explain to you
know how we get the islets out.
That was a picture,
by the way, of islets
under a microscope stained
with a dithizone dye that
stains the zinc.
Because zinc and
insulin are very closely
linked Studying the
zinc inside the islet,
so you can see then quite
clearly under the microscope.
Those are very pure
islets ready for infusion.
But we don't just get
the islets from anywhere.
They come from a human pancreas.
So I'm just going to walk
you through this process,
because it is quite a complex
process that our team has
to do in Edmonton.
So here they take
a pancreas, they
canulate the pancreas duct.
And as we're going through
the video here on the right,
I'll show you the
graph on the left there
is all those little dots, sort
of like the stars in the night,
every one of those represents
over 1,500 islet isolations
done by our team over
the last 15 years.
There's a human
pancreas on the right,
you can see it being distended
with collagenase enzymes
before we chop it up and put it
in Camillo Ricordi's chamber.
So there's Doug shaking
the chamber there.
This team's a very
well-knit team.
They work day and night
to prepare the cells.
Once the cells are
digested, then we
purify them on a continuous
ficoll gradient on a cool code
machine.
And there's Doug and Tatsuya
and the team at Edmonton
that prepare these cells for us.
They've done a
terrific job for us.
You can't see that
graph on the right,
it's a little too small for
you, but basically the number
of islets they get
out of the pancreas
today is double
the number that we
were able to get in
2000, when we first
began the Edmonton protocol.
And their success rate in
being able to take a pancreas
and provide enough
cells to transplant
has also increased to
around 60% to 70% percent.
The actual transplant
part is very, very simple.
It doesn't require
a transplant surgeon
to do this, fortunately.
So the transplant is done
in the x-ray department
under local anesthetic.
Here's a patient who
is awake, chatting away
during the procedure.
We use fluoroscopy x-ray so we
can see where the needle goes.
We thread a catheter into
the main portal vein there,
and then we simply drip
the cells in under gravity.
And we measure the
portal pressure
while we do this, we give
heparin to prevent blood
clotting at the end, before
we pull that catheter out.
Because we learned this perhaps
in our first early cases,
when we pulled the
catheter out of the liver,
we initially got bleeding.
So we found that when we put
this paste in along the track
as we pull it out, we
mix it up with contrast
so that we can see it being
injected on the x-ray screen.
You'll see that in a second
here as we load the syringe,
this is Aventine paste.
So as we pull the catheter out,
we plug the track in the liver.
And that has eliminated
the risk of complications
such as bleeding after
the islet transplant
So this is a very
safe procedure.
And if we look at the
number of patients
we've treated over the course
of time now, 97% of patients
survive.
And these are
patients, of course,
who have had longstanding
diabetes, who
are at risk of many
different things.
And of the few deaths that
we've encountered over 15
years have been mainly
cardiovascular deaths
in patients with
longstanding diabetes.
So heart attacks, basically.
So we've had four patients
die of heart attacks.
One patient had a possible
Creutzfeld-Jakob disease.
And one patient had
fatal hypoglycemia
after an early transplant
where the cells failed.
So none of these deaths have
been related to the transplant
or to the anti-rejection
drug treatment today.
So this has been a
very safe transplant,
certainly the safest transplant
that I've been involved in.
There have been adverse events.
We can go through
these, but I won't
go to them in too much detail.
A couple of patients
over 15 years-- 1.4%--
needed to go on to get
a kidney transplant,
because the drug we give to
prevent rejection to crolimus
does have kidney side effects.
Now what about performance?
Are we doing better over time?
So if we look at the
function of cells over time,
in the red line here.
So every molecule
of insulin that's
made by the cells,
another molecule
is made called C-peptide.
And we can measure the
C-peptide in the bloodstream
with a simple blood test.
So you can see that over
the course of 15 years,
73% of patients continue
to make C-peptide
to a sufficient degree that
controls the hemoglobin A1c,
therefore reduces
their risk of getting
the complications of
diabetes, and prevents
the patients from getting
hypoglycemic events.
So this is a real advance,
particularly for patients
that have really recalcitrant
risk of hypoglycemia.
So these patients are
very well protected.
But what we did see in the
early Edmonton protocol series
is that a large
number of patients
did need to go back on to
small amounts of insulin--
around 15% of patients--
by the 15-year mark.
And so we've spent
a lot of effort
now in the last
several years seeing
if we can improve these results
over the course of time.
And if you can think of
the number of the cells
that we transplant in to
liver here as a bucket,
and the cells are being
lost through little holes
in the bucket, we've
been working in science
to see if we can plug
the holes in the bucket
to try to allow more cells
to survive over time.
So we've been looking
at various pathways
to reduce early
damage to the cells,
trying to prevent them from
being rejected and preventing
leg graft loss, and
then really trying
to improve the number
of cells that we put in
at the beginning, so that
we can have many, many more
patients with fuller
function and more
durable function over time.
Now because type 1 diabetes
is an autoimmune condition,
as we mentioned
at the beginning,
there is a risk of the
autoimmunity coming back again.
And here's a patient's
biopsy-- and I
won't go through
too much details--
but you can see on
the right hand side,
there are islets
surviving quite well,
but no beta cells in
that biopsy, which
is from Dr. Razinia's group in
University of Massachusetts.
So we need processes that
can control rejection, reduce
inflammation, and allow the
patients to become tolerant.
In other words, for
the future, we'd
like to have a cell
treatment that we just
put into the patients that
the patients won't reject
on their own, and won't need
lifelong anti-rejection drugs.
And we're all trying
to get to that point
where we can achieve that.
And controlling this triangle
is a bit of a challenge,
but we're working on
it very intensively
as a global community of
diabetes research scientists.
And we're trying various
different maneuvers--
I mentioned a few of them that
I won't go through the details--
but I've mentioned a few of
them that we're trying presently
in Edmonton.
Now I showed you that
falloff an insulin
independence rates
at five years.
And now there are 6 centers
across the world that
have insulin-free
rates with islet cell
transplant of five
years, more than 50%.
And this is an
important milestone,
because it's exactly the
same rate that we would
see with a whole pancreas
transplant alone,
so a big operation
in comparison.
Putting a whole
pancreas transplant in,
connecting the blood vessels
up, and the risks from that.
We can achieve today-- at
least in these 6 centers-- very
similar results to the whole
pancreas transfer alone,
with a simple
injection in the site.
So in trying to control
the immune response.
We've tried this
treatment in Edmonton
now in over 100
patients-- I need
to update those
numbers-- on over 100
patients in various
different protocols
over the course of time.
And what we found in our
earlier analysis is basically
if we look at the
C-peptide rates,
they're very similar,
perhaps a little bit better
with the the
Alemtuzumab than they
were with the Edmonton
protocol, 84% at seven
years with C-peptide function.
And if we look at the
independence rates--
these are patients who are
fully free of insulin-- again,
ongoing data still in analysis
phase, but 58% of our patients,
when we last analyzed
this at seven years,
were still free of insulin.
Significantly improved from
our original Edmonton protocol
data, where currently at 15
years, just 11% of patients
remain insulin-free.
I mentioned the hemoglobin
A1c-- the glycated hemoglobin--
this marker in the
bloodstream that tells you
how good the blood
sugar control is.
And you can see at the
beginning where it says pre
there, on the left hand
side of your screen,
that the levels are
around 8% or 9%.
And the red line
is the threshold
of what a normal
person would have,
who doesn't have diabetes.
Now as we bring the line closer
and closer to the red line,
then the risk of getting
secondary complications
is obviously reduced markedly.
But normally, if we did
that with injected insulin
from the outside, the closer we
got to the red line, the more
and more dangerous hypoglycemias
the patient would have.
Well after the islet
cell transplant,
we can achieve the
below the red line
or under the red
line very reliably
without the risk
of hypoglycemia.
And these graphs show you the
different measures that we use.
Beforehand, you see
the patients have
a sky-high risk of hypoglycemia,
and this score is about five
on that score.
On the hypo score,
it's around 1,200.
And afterward, you
can see it's almost
undetectable over
the course of time.
So patients are
completely protected,
as long as the cells
continue to function,
from hypoglycemia and
swings in blood sugar.
So this is a very
effective treatment
for controlling blood sugar.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I feel my control
now is the best
it's ever been in 20 years.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO:
What about the risk
of the secondary complications?
There are several
centers looking at this.
Garth Warnock Vancouver has
looked at this quite closely.
What he finds in a control
group with islet transplant
versus conventional, or best
medical care insulin therapy,
is the islet transplant group
has much lower hemoglobin
A1c in the green.
They have less risk
of eye disease.
And their kidneys are
actually protected,
despite the fact that they
are receiving tacrolimus.
So this is very
encouraging data to suggest
that an islet or
other cell transplant,
or stem cell transplant in
the future for diabetes,
will have these
similar effects, being
able to protect against
the secondary complications
of diabetes.
We're working with the
US FDA quite closely
in two major trials were part
of the clinical islet transplant
consortium.
One is called CIT-06 and
one is called CIT-07.
And basically to
make it very simple,
one is islet after
kidney transplants,
in the 07 one are islets alone.
These trials are now
completed or undergoing
a very detailed analysis with
the FDA, and very likely,
these two trials will
lead to the FD awarding
a biological license for
islet transplantation,
allowing Medicare, Medicaid,
and third party payers
to potentially reimburse islet
transplant in the US, which
has been a major limiting factor
in terms of the numbers of cell
transplants done in the US.
We've been very fortunate
in Canada however
to have the Canadian government
pay-- the Alberta government,
I should say-- pay for
the Canadian transplants
to this point.
And a similar thing
has happened in the UK
with the National Institute
of Clinical Excellence paying
for islet transplant
through the UK government.
Same thing in Australia, same
thing in Europe, and Geneva,
and in several other countries.
So hopefully this will
happen very soon in the US.
Several groups have
reported the ability
to achieve what I showed you
with two islet transplants
with a single donor
islet infusion.
And this would be
important because it
would allow twice the
number of patients
to receive transplants from
a limited donor source,
from organ donors.
And so several centers
have been able to do
that with different strategies.
But still this is a challenge,
I would say, for us.
Only about 10% of our
patients in Edmonton
are able to achieve insulin
independence routinely.
If we don't select the donor,
we don't select the recipient
entirely.
What we do find if we look
at Melena Bellin's analysis?
Looking at all the
patients treated
that are participating in these
centers, that at five years,
if we give an anti-inflammatory
treatment at the beginning
called Tanacet-- which prevents
an inflammatory agent called
TNF-- if we switch that
off at the beginning,
we can have many, many
more patients of insulin
at five years.
Seems to be very important
to suppress inflammation
at the beginning.
So we've done studies in mice.
We always take things back
to mice and test things.
And we tested another compound
called Anakinra, which
is another antibody--
which is also
an anti-inflammatory one used
in inflammatory bowel disease
and another condition
called psoriasis--
and we found that this is
a very effective treatment
to allow human islets
to engraft in mice.
And we've been able to take that
treatment across to the clinic
and treat many
patients that way.
We've also been trying to
switch off the cell death
pathways in this pathway
called apoptosis.
So cells die by
different processes,
but we've tried several agents
to switch off cell death.
These are called pan
caspase inhibitors,
because they switch off
all the major cell death
pathways that lead
to this apoptosis.
And when we've tested these in
our mouse models and our pig
models, we find that
these caspase inhibitors
can reduce the tiny
number of islets needed
to reverse diabetes
by about 80%.
So they make a big,
big difference.
And we've tested
this several times
in various different
combinations
and various different ways.
And we've moved on and carried
out the early clinical trial
with these that looks--
well at this point,
it's difficult to say whether
it's had a big impact.
But we're still working on it.
So we recognize today that
islet transplantation,
the way it is today,
because patients
need immunosuppression, because
there is a shortage of organ
donors, could only
really address
a very narrow band in
the spectrum of patients
with diabetes.
And we'd like to get
to this point here
where we can treat all
the patients that are just
diagnosed with diabetes, that
have difficult to control
diabetes, that have
chronic type I diabetes,
and also those that
have type 2 diabetes--
the entire spectrum of diabetes.
And we recognize
that if we keep going
the way we are going
on that one track,
we won't be able to address
that entire spectrum.
So what next?
So we're looking at
alternative retrievable sites
to put in islets today, or stem
cells potentially tomorrow.
And here's a trial
that we're actively
involved in now with a
company called Sernova.
And this is a device
that goes under the skin.
It's the the size and
shape of a tea bag.
And it basically threads
in under the skin.
We leave it there for
about a month or two.
And while it's
under the skin here,
the body makes new blood
vessels that grow in.
And this is a sort of in
response to a foreign body.
Then we take those rods
out when we come back.
And we can do this under
a local anesthetic,
we can do this under
a general anesthetic.
And then we can infuse
ourselves along that track,
and basically put the cells
in under the skin instead
of in in liver.
Now that may be an advantage,
but as we think to the future,
as we think about
use of stem cells,
it might be safer to put
them in a retrievable place
where we can take them
out if we need to.
So if we put them under the
skin instead of the liver,
it's a much simpler maneuver
to take the cells out.
So we've done this so
far in a few patients,
and it's looked
somewhat promising
in terms of being able
to show cell survival.
But this is still ongoing,
and we're looking at the data
closely.
We've also been looking at what
we call the deviceless method.
So we put a tube under the skin.
We leave the tube under the
skin-- a simple catheter
that we use routinely
in the x-ray department.
We leave that catheter
under the skin for a month.
We take the calculator out,
and then we put our cells,
or stem cells, or
islets, or whatever kind
of cell population
we want to put in,
in this track, which has now got
lots of nice new blood vessels.
And here you can
see islets surviving
in that round area
that used to have
the little catheter
on the top left there.
And the cells work very well.
And you can see with the
catheter placed under the skin,
and then we put the
cells in the blue line,
blood glucose comes
down quite nicely,
It takes a few weeks to do so.
And you can see on
the right, we get
lots of nice new blood
vessels growing in
to supply these cells.
So I mentioned islet transplants
today, and stem cells tomorrow.
So I think we are
getting very close now
to being able to move
forward with stem cell
treatments instead of islet
cell transplant treatments
for the next round of
trials for the future.
There are several
groups across the world
working on stem cells.
And I'll show first
just one that we're
collaborating with,
Maria Nostro and Gordon
Keller at the
University of Toronto
have made a stem
cell line that makes
human insulin-- the human beta
cells, basically-- from stem
cells.
And we've been able to reverse
diabetes quite effectively
in mice and our deviceless
model with that cell system.
We've also been testing out
to see if the cells turn out
to have what's
called a teratoma,
or risk of awry cells, then
they can be transplanted still
in this deviceless space
and not breach the space,
so we can still
potentially remove them.
We've also been working
for the last 10 years
with a company called
Viacyte down in San Diego.
And we've been very
excited by that progress
in developing a human embryonic
stem cell line that they have
shown can reliably
make human insulin,
and can be potentially
transplanted,
and can cure diabetes in
mice when transplanted.
And this group has
been very innovative
and shown these
cells to be safe,
to have no risk of the
teratoma that I mentioned.
And they are now carrying
out a clinical trial
that we're looking
forward to participate in,
where we're going to put
these cells inside what's
called an immunoisolating
device, so
that the immune
system can't directly
get cell-to-cell contact
with the transplanted cells.
And the idea of that
is that we wouldn't
have to give the
anti-rejection drug treatments
if it's effective.
So we're looking forward
to starting these trials
with Viacyte within
the next few months.
Now in parallel, there's
lots of other treatments
that could
potentially switch off
the autoimmune pathways
in type 1 diabetes.
And Jeff Bluestone,
from San Francisco here,
has summarized all
the different pathways
that can be switched off in type
1 diabetes, all the studies,
all the antibodies, all
the drug treatments that
can be given to try
and control diabetes.
And it's obviously
a very complex one.
We've amassed a team in
Alberta to try and address
one or two of these
together with industry
and a large collaboration
of scientists
in Edmonton and Calgary.
We're going to do
two different trials.
One is trying to get
patients' own stem
cells to regenerate
their own pancreas as
soon as the patient is
diagnosed with diabetes.
In other words, resetting
the immune system
and getting the
patient's own cells
to turn back and
repair the beta cells.
And then the second
strategy we're using
is the Viacyte cell transplants
to try to treat patients
just like we would at the
Edmonton protocol type
treatments that I
showed you about.
So the immune reset
is moving forward.
We've got our plans in place.
We're just putting
them through ethics
and through Health
Canada right now.
We're going to give antibody
treatments at the beginning
to reset the immune system.
We're going to take the
patient's own bone marrow cells
and re-transplant those
up into the pancreas
to allow those cells to
repair the injured pancreas.
Then we're going to give a
treatment for the first year,
called a GLP-1 analog,
that will help to further
regenerate and
accelerate the growth
and repair of injured islets.
So we have a lot
of things to do,
and we're very, very
excited about it.
We're also working
with another technology
called normothermic perfusion.
And this is going
to I think really
revolutionize all areas
of transplantation.
So most the time you can see
those boxes on the right,
that's how we carry
organs around, in ice.
So hearts, lungs,
livers, kidneys,
and the pancreas
for our islets--
we carry them in these boxes.
So we're just about
to start a trial
with a group at the
University of Oxford,
and a company called
OrganOx, where
they have one device that
we could put a liver on,
which is in this
bottom left panel.
There's other companies that
have a device for hearts,
for lungs.
And here's one that
we're testing out
for pancreas transplantation.
So in other words, instead
of putting the organ in ice
and having it
injured, we can keep
it perfectly alive--
like the heart's beating
there-- outside the body.
And so as soon as
we transplant it,
it can be in perfect
condition when
we transplant these organs.
It'll make a big, big difference
to the safety of transplants,
and also to make sure that
the transplants really
work before we put them in.
And the idea here is that we
can deliver oxygen, deliver
nutrients, provide a
physiological temperature,
and provide an ideal
environment for the organ
while it's outside of the body.
So we're very excited about this
technology as well as we move
forward.
And this is the liver machine
that we're about to test.
And the company who
came to San Diego
to the World Transplant
Congress mentioned to me
that they'd love
to have Google's
logo on the outside of the box.
So, if you're interested
in working with them,
just let them know.
So let me sum up.
So I showed you that we've
made a lot of progress
in the treatments of diabetes
over the course of time.
That insulin dependence
rates have improved a lot.
That several centers now have
over half of their patients
still free of
insulin at five years
after an islet transplant.
That we're looking now to
other alternative sites
for infusing islets
under the skin.
I didn't mention
other sites that we're
about to test with
the Pittsburgh group,
including the lining
of the stomach.
We're about to start trials with
Viacyte on their embryonic stem
cell treatments.
And we're also looking
at regeneration trials
to regenerate and repair
the pancreas and the islets
that at the moment a child or
adult is diagnosed with type 1
diabetes.
So there's a lot of
things happening.
I think we'll make
a lot of progress.
So finally today, I'm very much
looking forward to discussing
with the contact lens team
our opportunities of working
together in cell
transplant monitoring,
and also with the
Google Glass team,
looking at the role
of the Google Glasses
and state-of-the-art monitoring
and complex surgeries.
A guy was telling
me about the use
of these in lung
transplantation.
I think we could apply this
very easily also in liver
transplantation, maybe join
the pancreas islet isolation.
I think also this could
allow us to communicate
far better as scientists from
one institution to another.
So instead of me being in
Edmonton, another group
being in San Francisco,
another group being
in Australia, another
group being in China,
we could make a
scientific community that
is basically global
and one, and allow
us to work much closer together.
And that's what I'm
very excited about.
So on behalf of our
pre-clinical team scientists
that have done all the
hard work-- our PhDs,
our master students,
our post-docs,
and technicians that
have done really
all the hard work and
pre-clinical testing--
on behalf of our
large clinical team
that has basically helped up
prepare the islet transplants.
So thank you very much
indeed for the opportunity
to present to you
this afternoon.
I look forward to
answering your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: My name is Zerga.
I actually work on
the iris and basically
the contact lens project here.
So I've heard some questions
about the cells you infuse.
So can you tell us some very
basic biology of those cells?
So when you inject it into the
blood vessels of the kidney,
where do they end up?
So do they actually stay
there and live in the kidney?
Or do they end up
in the pancreas?
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO:
So the question
is-- so we transplant our
cells inside the liver.
So it's a local injection
literally inside like this,
under x-ray.
And we get the radiologist
to put a catheter
into the main vein that
goes up into the liver.
It's called the portal vein.
And it's like a tree.
It has main trunks, and
it has little branches.
And the islet cells, the
vary in size, from about 50
microns to 150
micrometers in size.
Some are larger-- 400 or
500 micrometers in size.
And basically they
go up this tree,
and they go far along
the tree until they
get into a blood vessel
that's smaller than they are.
There they get trapped.
And basically a little bit of
blood clot forms around them,
and a local inflammatory
reaction-- then new blood
vessels grow in
inside the liver.
These cells are not going
back into the pancreas.
We could potentially put
them in the pancreas,
but it would be very, very
technically difficult to do so.
It would be risky.
It could case pancreatitis.
It could be a difficult
place to put them.
It just so happens that the
liver is a very effective place
to put these cells.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: Potentially
they can grow anywhere.
The question will be will
the cells work as effectively
in another site as they
do currently in the liver.
And we don't know that yet.
AUDIENCE: How do they
communicate with the body?
When do they know
when to generate--
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: How do
they communicate with the body
was the question.
So the islets have
sensors on them.
So they have glucose
receptors and they
can sense the blood
sugar, much the same way
you do with a skin test when
you take a drop of blood.
They're listening to the
blood stream, monitoring it
constantly, all the time.
And as soon as the blood glucose
goes high, then in concert,
they all release just the
right amount of insulin
that's needed in a
very dynamic way.
And as the blood sugar drops
below a certain threshold,
they all shut off, so
they stop making insulin.
So it's a much more precise
way of regulating blood sugar
than if you inject
insulin from the outside.
So it's able to do
that because they're
a collection of cells
there that adjust insulin.
And i didn't mention, the islets
have several cell populations
int them.
The have the beta cells
that make insulin.
They also have another
cell population
called alpha cells
that make glucagon.
And glucagon makes
the blood sugar go up.
So you have what's called
counter regulatory control.
So with counter
regulatory control,
you can keep your blood sugar
in a very precise balance.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Dr. Shapiro.
My name's Joel.
My wife has lived with type 1
diabetes for nearly 40 years.
And she had a couple questions.
The short one is-- do you
transplant the entirety
of the islet, or
just the beta cells?
And the more interesting,
or more complex
question is-- are you
modifying the islet cells prior
to transplant to reduce the
chance they'll be attacked
by the same antibodies
that originally
killed of the islet cells?
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: So the
islets that we transplant
are the collection
of all the cells.
So there's five-- I mentioned
two cell types-- there
are actually five or six
different cell types.
Maybe there's even more that
we haven't discovered yet.
But the islet is sort of
an organelle collection
of several types.
We think that the islet
needs all of those cell types
in order to survive
in the longer term.
If you just took out
all the beta cells
and transplanted them, they
might work for a while.
But maybe the beta
cells on their own,
without the rest of
the supported matrix
and the ability to communicate
with each other in this sort
of local mode, maybe they
wouldn't work as well.
We don't know that.
But we transplant
all of the cells.
And so the second question was--
AUDIENCE: Do you do anything
to modify the islet cells prior
to transplant?
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO:
Do we do anything.
And so, the islets are
taken out of the pancreas
in that process.
We keep them in culture.
Now in the old days, in the very
first experiments we've done,
there was a lot of different
innovations that we had done.
You could treat them
with ultraviolet light.
You could treat
them with x-rays.
You could treat them
with high oxygen.
And these would alter what
is called the immunogenicity,
or the ability of the body
to recognize them as foreign.
We haven't done so
much of that now.
But potentially you
can do a lot of things
to manipulate the
cells in the Petri dish
that could alter the
ability of the body
to recognize them as foreign.
we could wrap them in
a seaweed membrane,
an algenate microcapsule.
We could add other
products locally
around the islets
to protect them.
So an islet in some way
has a lot more potential
than the other
transplants that we do,
where we don't have that ability
to alter them in the dish.
But we haven't explored that
perhaps to its full potential.
Yeah, you're quite correct.
AUDIENCE: I noticed
in one of the slides
that the A1c's
that were reported,
or that were monitored in your
patients, seemed to improve
over time after the
transplant, not just initially.
And given the propensity
of these cells to degrade,
I was surprised that it
got better as time went on.
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: I think
that's partly a function-- well
I should say hemoglobin
doesn't drop immediately.
The reason for that is it
takes two or three months
to have an effect.
So if you have bad
control, then you suddenly
go to perfect control,
the next A1c test
is reflecting what happened
three months earlier.
So there's a lag in
its ability to measure.
It's designed that
way, because it
is meant to tell
you what's happened
over the last few months.
So that's why you're
seeing a delay.
It's not so much that control
is improving over time,
but I think it's more that.
AUDIENCE: And just sort of
a more general follow up.
I've been diabetic for 25 years.
And ever since I
was diagnosed I've
been following the news media
and basically, the light
at the end of the tunnel has
been there the whole time.
Does seem to getting
brighter, but what
is your take on kind
of a realistic timeline
for-- I realize it's
all speculation.
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO:
So if I send you back
to your office this
afternoon in Google and say,
I want you to tell me
in a week how long it's
going to take to
finish a project.
Maybe you've got all the
algorithms straightened out,
and you can tell me it's
going to take exactly a week.
I think for this, because
it's a biological system,
it's working humans, it's
not just all of that.
We also have to deal with
the regulatory agencies
as soon as we want to
do something different.
We've got to justify
what we're doing.
They often tell us to go
back and do more experiments.
So you'll notice I never
mentioned the five year cure.
I never said, well, we'll
do this in five years
or we'll do it in 10 years.
What I will say to you
is that in 2014 we're
doing far more in
this year than I ever
dreamed we would
be at this point.
So my impression is that we're--
all of us as a community--
are moving faster.
We haven't got there yet.
I don't know how long it's going
to take to get to the light
at the end of the tunnel.
But I know that's
where we want to be.
But it's going to
take what it takes,
provided we're all
working intensively
in the right direction.
AUDIENCE: My name is Steven.
I also work on the
contact lens project.
And so I have a
question a little bit
related to Zach's question.
The islet function is
said to be modulated
by the autonomic nervous
system, parasympathetic, and
sympathetic nervous system.
Alpha and beta insulin
and glucagon production.
And so if you place these cells
underneath the skin, what's
the effect of breaking
the autonomic link so
you have some autonomous
function in response
to glucose.
You cut off this nervous
system link, so--
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO:
You're quite correct.
So the islets that
are transplanted
are completely detonated.
They don't have any
nerves going into them.
Potentially the nerves
can grow in over time,
along with the new-- blood
vessels happen first.
Potentially they can
become integrated.
But the nerve end
growth isn't essential.
So perhaps it helps with the
a cued release of insulin
in the normal individual
who's stressed.
But most of the time these cells
can respond very effectively
to the local environment.
So you don't need innovation.
And they clearly
can work just fine,
as I showed you,
without innovation.
You can divide the
vagus nerves in patients
that don't get diabetes.
Often we do that for
other conditions.
So it clearly plays
a role somehow,
but it's probably
a very minor role,
because it's just
completely redundant.
You don't need it.
AUDIENCE: So there
was a research article
that I came across recently
about activating islet cell
production in the
gastrointestinal tract.
And I was wondering if
you could talk about that.
I don't recall seeing
it on the slides.
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO:
So there's a group
led by Dr. Tim Kieffer
in Vancouver, who's
worked on trying to
convert the cells
in the gastrointestinal
tract into becoming
insulin-making beta cells.
That's really his
area of expertise.
He's made a lot of progress
over the course of time.
But I don't think I can
beyond that comment directly
on his work, because I haven't
been directly involved in it.
But it's exciting.
AUDIENCE: How does the
life look for the patient
after the transplant, in terms
of taking the immunosuppression
drugs, and what's
the cost of it,
and how often it has
to be administered.
And what are the
side effects of it?
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: Right.
So the standard
anti-rejection drugs
are usually taken twice a day.
And most patients tolerate
these extremely well.
And we do a lot of
testing beforehand
to weed out the odd patient
that won't tolerate it well.
So we look for patients who
have bad kidney function,
and we won't give them a
transplant, because we don't
want to push them
into kidney failure.
But it's usually a twice
daily drug regimen.
Most patients tolerate
it quite well.
Some people get a
tremor in the hands.
Some people got
some leg swelling.
Some people get mouth ulcers.
There's various
different side effects--
the whole panoply
of side effects
can happen-- bit generally most
patients tolerate them well.
One thing we don't hear though
in the islet transplants
is to avoid the steroids.
So steroids used to have
a lot of side effects
after transplant.
They would give you
puffiness in the face,
actually cause diabetes
in some patients,
cause overweight, cause various
issues, mood disturbance.
So we're not giving
any steroids at all
in the islet cell transplants.
So the side effects are probably
minimized because of that.
They're not zero.
And the side effects that you
don't see but you worry about
are the risk of cancers
and the risk of infections.
So we tell every
patient coming in
that they have an increased
risk of certain cancers,
skin cancers, blood cancers,
and certain infections that
could potentially kill them.
And the way I look
upon it and discuss it
with the patient is if they have
bad control of their diabetes
anyway, then the risks
attendant to the drugs
are actually a
drop in the ocean,
very small compared
to the big risks
they face every day
from their diabetes.
If they have perfect
control of their diabetes,
then it's a different matter.
Is they are well-controlled
with insulin,
then on the other hand,
I would say, "Well, you
don't want to face
the risk of infection.
You don't want to face the
increased risk of cancer
if your diabetes is being
managed perfectly the way
it is already."
And that's really
the rationale for us
picking the worst of the worst
patients in terms of the blood
sugar control.
Insulin is of course very cheap.
The immunosuppressive
drugs can be expensive.
The costs are changing
over the course of time
now because all of the
patents on these earlier drugs
have ended.
So there are generics coming in,
and the costs are coming down.
They're still not zero.
And it depends on the patient's
drug plan and their ability
to get reimbursed for it.
So in Canada, most the time
it has not been a problem.
Occasional patients have not had
full coverage for their drugs.
But generally it can be managed.
FEAUDIENCE: Could you comment
on the transition from islets
to stem cells?
How do you make
them differentiate
into the right thing?
And does it happen inside
or outside of the body?
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: Stem cells
are, of course, exciting
in many ways, because it
means that instead of relying
on going through that complex
process of making the cells,
you have a limitless
supply that could
treat the whole population
in the world with Type 1
and Type 2 diabetes.
That would be really,
really exciting.
But as you move
forward, you've got
a whole new gamut
of testing to do.
You have to be sure
they're going to be safe.
You've got to be sure
that when you put them in,
they're not going to cause
uncontrolled drop in blood
sugar.
We don't think that's
going to happen.
But it could.
We've got to be sure
that they're not
going to turn into
cancers, or precancers,
or some other worrisome
transformation
once we transplant the cells.
We know that islet cells,
when we transplant them,
stay very stable.
But these other
cells-- these stem
cells-- they can turn
into any cell potentially.
So there's a lot of
caution as we move forward,
as well as a lot of excitement.
So it has to be done very
carefully, step by step.
Can we make the cells
differentiate and make them
into perfect islets
and stable islets
before we transform them?
That's what we'd like to do.
But the stem cell scientists
that make these cells
have not yet been able
to completely overcome
that hurdle.
So they're giving us the cells
that they make-- manufacture--
are still these pre-islet cells.
And they turn into islets
once they're transplanted.
So they're working
very hard trying
to understand the
messaging systems
in the body as an
embryo grows, what
controls the differentiation,
what controls
the stabilization from
one step to the next.
And I think until they've done
that fully, we'll probably
still be transplanting these
precursor cells for a while,
until we have the--
yeah, ideally we'd
like to have perfect human
islets, look like human islets,
they taste like human islets,
they work like human islets,
and they stay that way forever.
But I don't think
we're there yet.
And perhaps we're
never get there.
But hopefully we will.
FEAUDIENCE: I
understand that you
know, when you were
first doing trials,
you were using the worst case
scenario patients-- terribly
brittle diabetics-- in
whom you were hoping
to provide some relief
without causing long term
complications from all of the
immunosuppressants and robbing
Peter to pay Paul.
So I'm wondering now
in the current trials,
if we're starting to
broaden those inclusion
criteria a little bit?
Or where are we now with that?
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: We haven't
really broadened the criteria.
So very fair question.
We haven't done that.
We're still concentrated
on the brittle patients.
Occasionally, we'll see a
patient come to us and say,
"I'm just tired of
having diabetes.
I'm tired of testing.
I've worked pretty hard at it.
I'm tired of it.
But my control right
now is pretty good."
That's a hard one for
us, because we say, "OK.
We understand where you're at.
But we don't want to
do any harm to you."
It's so much easier to take
somebody who you've worked on,
you've tried.
If despite your best
efforts as a diabetes
and an endocrinologist
to control them.
If you fail, then there's
nothing else left.
And then it's easy for us.
So have we reached
the point where
we could transition and
open it up to more patients?
I think we probably have.
I mean, I think at
the beginning we
didn't know what
the real risks were.
We didn't know what the
risk of plotting off
the vein and the liver,
the portal vein thrombosis
would be.
We didn't know the
risk of bleeding.
The procedure risk.
We knew there's be a risk of
cancers and life-threatening
infections, but we didn't really
have a quantification of it.
I think now, and
I've shown you data,
I think we do have
quantification of it.
So we could have a very fair
discussion with the patient.
Say look, these
are the real risks.
These are the potential
benefits to you.
If you like it.
Sure.
And I think to
get to that point,
we probably need to do a
randomized controlled trial.
Best instant therapy against
the islet transplant.
And you come in with a
ticket at the beginning,
you either win an
islet transplant,
or you win the pump.
And the problem with that--
we want to do that trial.
We'd all love to do that trial.
The problem is, who's
going to fund it?
Who's going to pay for it?
And we don't have anybody
that's come forward to say,
we really want to do that trial.
We'll fund it for you.
Maybe Google would.
FEAUDIENCE: What would the
cost of a trial like that be?
And not that any of our
budgets can cover that, but
and also if we were wanting to
donate to diabetes research,
are there any
organizations that you
think are particularly--
maybe excluding yours--
to be unbiased, although
you can mention it,
that you think would
be particularly useful?
DR. JAMES SHAPIRO: OK.
Maybe I'll answer
the second one first.
So there are several
organizations--
international organizations
that raise money for diabetes.
Juvenile Diabetes Research
Foundation, The American
Diabetes Foundation, Canadian
Diabetes Foundations,
and many others.
So I don't think I can
concentrate on one.
It wouldn't be fair
for me to do that.
What I will tell you is that
in order to get to this point,
we've all done a
lot of research.
And in order to get
to the next point,
we've got an enormous
amount of research to go.
And I'm not sure that any of
these organizations, including
the NIH, including the Kidney
Institute of Health research,
including several other global
funding research organizations.
We're challenged.
We don't have sufficient
funds to accelerate this.
And so we need funds.
So if we wanted to
do a trial, and let's
say we powered it
reasonably with five or 10
years of followup, and we
looked at complications.
And we wanted ideally, probably
50, 60 patients in each arm.
And the control
group patients would
be receiving standard
diabetes care anyway,
but they would
need extra testing.
And in the islet transplant
group you can-- in Canada,
it cost us $75,000
per transplant.
Two transplants, $150,000
in the first year.
Probably some additional
research costs for patients.
So $200,000.
I don't Know.
If you want me to
guess, it's the order
of the maybe $10 million. $10
million to $20 million perhaps.
I'd have to work it out more.
But it's not billions.
It's doable.
FRANK: OK.
And with that, thank
you all for coming.
And thank you very
much, Dr. Shapiro
for taking the time
to speak to us today.
[APPLAUSE]